hello it's a pleasure to be speaking
with you during this session today i'd
like to talk to you at a very high level
on how agriculture's changing and how
sustainability enabled by regenerative
agriculture
fits into that and what the role of the
plant breeder are
the changing ag landscape is really
different by three interacting mega
factors society largest small food
companies and clothing companies and
global and local policy
and as we dig into
thinking what does society want it's
really about what's called the evolution
of the green revolution now what do i
mean by that i mean that of course
society continues to be interest and are
we producing enough do we have enough
food to feed a hungry planet but in
addition to that they want us to evolve
into thinking about how was that food
grown as a grown in responsible way and
what is the nutritional value of that
food
and of course society continues to be
concerned about the availability of
clean water and climate
the good news is they're starting to see
farmers as the solution to these issues
large companies are responding to
society's pressures and they are
literally putting millions of dollars
into helping the farmers in their value
chain
move to regenerative ag on millions of
acres and it's not just large companies
it's many small companies also doing
this and policymakers are responding to
pressures from companies and society
and as you think about this it's it's
not just one place it's not just europe
it's global
i have to say 2021 is the most active
year in global meetings on the food
system and policy discussions that i've
ever seen
and there are billions of dollars for
example coming from usda to enable
regenerative ag principles we truly are
at an inflection point as we think about
global policy in this space
and so where are the farmers in all this
well at the same time when they're
trying to understand all these external
landscape pressures they're asking
themselves the same question they've
always asked themselves and they're
thinking about low margins or thinking
about profitability
uh they're thinking about weather
extremes or thinking about potential
regulations all of which which make this
even harder
they're starting to become much more
aware of the soil wall soil degradation
and they're concerned about water do
they have enough water for their
livestock do they have enough water for
their crops and do is their water clean
enough for their children just like
everybody else they want clean and
healthy food and water for the children
and they want to be good stewards of the
land
and so many of the farmers are really
starting to think about and see
regenerative back principles as a
possible path forward
they're curious about they're wondering
is this for me
so where do plant breeders fit in all
this well we must focus on farmer needs
that has to be our first responsibility
we have to think about how our solutions
enable what they need on the farm
but we also must interact
listen and learn from society
companies policy makers so we can so we
can co-evolve and think about how to
create this green revolution that is
economically and fair and viable for the
farmer
one way we can think about this as plant
breeding is to think about on-farm
sustainability and i can tell you from
the cortez side business and
sustainability is not ore it's a and
sustainability is not something that's
nice to do it's a must do
and if we we know if we do not do it we
will not have a business in the future
that is relevant
and our intentional our internal
innovation
is guided by sustainability goals tied
back to united nation goals so as plant
breeders we really need to start to
think about how our varieties lead to
sustainable cropping systems on the farm
and how will we do that
we'll think about breeding crops that
reduce risk increase resilience over
seasons
we'll we'll do that by creating these
healthy agricultural systems think about
soil health and soil function because it
is so important
to not only
on farm profitability productivity but
to to ecosystem services and the needs
of society
and and we have we continue to have an
issue with soils and it's it's not just
somewhere over there it's it's it's
where you live
in in the midwest there are
uh iowa has lost over 60 percent of its
top soil since 1850 we continue to lose
top soil in other areas
um you know i i have to say that farmers
are doing many things right they are
improving their practices they're
improving their tillage practices but
we're still seeing losses and we're
still seeing some issues
so what is what is one path forward many
people are thinking about being curious
about wondering about regenerative
agricultural principles
and there are many definitions for
regenerative agriculture but this is the
one car temp is using
it's a it's a farming system designed to
optimize profitability and
sustainability
while at the same time purposely
designed to replenish and improve
natural resources
which helps ensure production is
resilient for farmers and profitable for
farmers but it goes beyond just the
farmers it is thinking about how how
does this affect their communities how
does this affect society
and as i mentioned there's many
different different definitions for
regenerative agriculture but at the core
of all these there's these five
principles of soil health and it doesn't
matter if cortez talking about these
principles of soil
the nature conservancy general mills
patagonia usda soil health institute
it doesn't matter they all rally around
these same principles
and what are these principles they're
they're very high level they're really
very simple they're minimizing cell
disturbance they're keeping soil covered
they're encouraging variety and
biodiversity they're keeping lit living
roots in the soil
and they're thinking about how to
integrate crops and livestock
and the beauty with these principles is
they're universal they can be applied to
conventional organic farming it works
equally well for both
it works for row crops corn and soybeans
and in illinois and iowa
almonds and and
lettuce and california for specialty
crops and it also works for ranging
pastures and the other great thing about
these principles it doesn't matter if
you have a 10th a 10 000 acre farm in
iowa or a one hectare farm in uganda
these principles hold
and so as you think about this what what
it's really about is how do you take
these principles
and customize this and apply them
to an individual farm in an individual
sub-farm and how do we think about using
this for these principles to make the
farmer profitable and sustainable
and if we do this correctly it results
in what's called the triple win and a
simple way to say it is that by farming
with nature instead of against it
it will be good for the farmer it would
be good for the planet and it will be
good for the people and at the end of
the day
farmers will start to move to these
practices because it makes economic
sense for them to do so
with regenerative agriculture that the
driver is still really coming from the
crops and the varieties that that we
breed for the farmers
but it's it's crops across all the
seasons
and as the farmer starts to use
regenerative back principles
in the in the ecosystem the soil becomes
healthier it provides many benefits back
to the farming system
there's reduced inputs from that the
farmer has to do there's better water
management there's reduced operating
costs
there's long-term increased land value
and and there's
these ecosystem services clean water
carbon sequestration biodiversity which
of course are good for the planet and
society but they also provide money back
to the farm in the former credits and
incentives and make the farm much more
resilient and efficient over seasons
and as plant breeders
we must think about more than just plant
productivity we need to think about how
the crops we breed
affect things like water quality human
health
climate
and how that interacts with changing
management strategies that the farmers
are doing or thinking about doing
and how this leads to outcomes to keep
properties that we know we need
to do this we we must change our
thinking we must start to think more
like an ecologist or agroecologist and
have that mindset
of course we we need to continue to
think at the organism level we need to
think about individual plants
our genetics perform
uh in a population what how does that 40
acre filter corn perform for the farmer
but we must in addition to that we must
also think about how do we put these in
the context of the community how do we
think about this not just in one season
but across seasons not just one crop but
cover crops crop rotations management
practices
and and not just think about that farm
but how do we think about the ecosystem
and that that farm is part of that
watershed that the farm is part of
and this is difficult to do because
we've all been trained to have this
reductionist approach
many times we fail to understand that
these cropping systems are communities
and we and if we do that we lose the
ability to really take advantage of that
community level emerging qualities that
we're all looking for so bottom line the
plant breeders just cannot focus on what
crop one season
it must be done in the context of this
larger system
the interaction between crop and the
ecosystem is being grown in is amazingly
complex and we have so much we need to
learn i was really struck by the
reflections of tom oglemeyer as he
talked about this
he said for me it reminds him of the
1950s
when people would go into the open
pollinated corn choose the big ears
and say these are the winners for next
year and plant them and be disappointed
the ears weren't big next year right
and it wasn't very predictive it was
like picking a derby horse by the color
and why wasn't it predictive well we
simply did not understand the underlying
science we didn't understand
quantitative genetics and we didn't take
into account the interaction of genetics
with the environment it was being grown
in the g by e
the good news now is that as breeders we
are starting to take
much more account of not just g by e but
g
genetics by environment by traits by
management
but what we need to do is start to
expand our thinking of management to
include
regenerative act principles and
practices and to include all the below
ground interaction with microbial
communities fungi and other soil life
that comes with healthy soils
and we have so much to learn before we
can really start to think about how do
we add that to our selection criteria
and to make our our job even more
challenging we must evolve into
including society into that interaction
and that index
we need to think about again how that
food was grown
and what is the nutritional value of
that food
the good news is uh there's
variation for almost everything
and the question for us is what are the
future breeding targets that farmers
care about
we we need to continue to consider the
needs the varieties that are designed to
thrive in complex rotations and
management systems we need to think
about things like short stature corn
quick maturing crops
but it's not just thinking about how our
core crops interact with these systems
we need to think about
breeding cover crops and service crops
the ones that fit the farming system
that is being used by our farmers and
ones that integrate with crops and
livestock
we need to listen and we need to
understand
to what our farmers are telling us we
need to understand what are the
attributes they are asking for in their
core crops into their cover crops and
then we need to turn those into breeding
targets
but it's more than just the farmer
targets we we need to think about what
is the variation available
for the future breeding targets for
society
we need those that include
nutrient density plants that are
optimized for ecosystem services
those types of attributes that work in
harmony with nature above and below the
soil
and we must also remember consumers are
not just focused on the farm
they are concerned with having a fair
and just market and they're very
concerned with having thriving farming
communities
and this all becomes really clear as you
think as you look at the 2021 united
nations food system
goals
it's easy to see what they're concerned
about at this global food system level
and at the bottom line we are not just
breeding for farmers we are breeding for
this global food system
and we need to think about what are the
attributes we need first
and then think about how do we leverage
breeding and technology to create
what many things change
some things continue to stay the same
and these two questions that i learned
40 years ago still hold right as you
think about your breeding program
it is what do you select for and then
how do you do it
uh and a couple things i do know as you
think about these questions
is that you cannot answer one of these
questions in absence
they must co-evolve in this internet
process between them
and they answer these questions as a
journey it's not something you can just
study and solve today and not have to
think about it again in the future
the other thing as you think about this
is
as we think about that how do you how do
you do it how do you best select
and you think about the technical
projects that go with it if it gets too
far ahead of the what should we be
selecting for
our projects are doomed to failure
because they will lose support
by our companies by our universities and
buyer farmers
and if the what we do select for is
thought of in the absence of society
environmental needs
the answer to the answer along with our
technical solutions will be less
relevant in the future of agriculture
and so why is this also important right
now
as we look at the current state of
agriculture most farmers in north
america
only use zero to one to two of these
principles and that's what we've been
primarily breeding and selecting for
but as we think about the future
most farmers are going to shift to using
more and more regenerative back
principles and why will this happen
again if it's some of it's for pressures
of society
and consumers and policy but mostly
it'll happen because it makes economic
sense for farmers to adopt these
practices on their farm
but as we think about plant breeding and
we continue to breed solutions and
targets
for those farming systems using zero to
one to two of these principles pretty
soon we're not going to be surfacing
very many farmers
so the question becomes how soon will we
shift
thinking about breeding for this more
complex regenerative ag future
and
and the decision we have is how fast
will we move
will we be proactive will we be reactive
and and as we think about this remember
even if these changes i'm describing
take 10 to 15 to 20 years it's still
only two to three breeding cycles away
so the last question i'll leave you with
is
are you ready for this change
and just a couple resources for you to
read through a couple really really good
books
and a couple good papers to read the
space so thank you for your time and i
look forward to your questions
you